well thanks so much for having me here I
guess we're a half real-life half
virtual but feel free to ask tons of
questions and interrupt me all the time
because it's much more entertaining for
me that way so yes I will be talking
about how not to generate random numbers
which is an extremely destructive title
for a talk I would rather well I don't
know if I would rather be constructive
maybe some of you would rather be
constructive but this is mostly about
how things are messed up rather than how
to fix them so for that I apologize
anyway okay well okay it's all of your
faults that's that's the lesson here all
right so I figured I would start with
making this concrete in case any of you
weren't quite sure what we were here
about so here's some here's a web page
maybe some of you visit it maybe some of
you don't but the relevant thing here is
this little green lock on the upper
corner and the HTTPS in the browser
you're in the URL so this is the browser
telling us that we have a secure
connection to this banking website which
we sure hope we do because we would
rather not have our username and
password stolen by some criminals on the
way we would rather not be visiting some
fake Bank of America side we would
rather be visiting the real one so these
are the assurances that this
cryptography is trying to tell us so we
can go in and click on these on this
little block and we can find out more
information about the cryptography that
is using so here we have some okay shot
ones with RSA encryption signatures and
then public key RSA encryption we've got
a public key we've got an exponent we've
got a key size whatever so there's lots
of things going on here
primitives I took this screenshot a
couple years ago so I don't know
somebody with a laptop open might my
check if they've updated it
I think chrome now gives you a little
yellow URL if it's using sha-1 okay so
at the sort of very high level what this
thing is doing when we connect to this
website is we're going to eventually be
doing some RSA encryption
so here's the textbook version of RSA
for you
we've got Alice and we've got Bob so
here I guess this is Bob calm and
Alice's you despite the fact that there
are no women in this room and okay so no
other women well I don't know I mean you
don't have any verification on me
neither
I could be a mirage I'm Leia in front of
you okay so all right so hopefully you
guys have all seen this before but this
is just to sort of fix ideas RSA the
everybody's favorite simple public key
cryptosystem also the first one we've
got a public key which is a modulus and
it's the product of two large Prime's P
and Q and we've got an encryption
exponent e and so the private key really
any of these values suffice is but
basically the factorization of n gives
you a decryption exponent D which is e
inverse mod fee of N and then okay so if
Alice wants to speak to Bob she asks Bob
for the public key that's containing
that certificate in the screenshot that
I showed you before then when Alice
wants to send Bob an encrypted message
like say her session key for the TLS
session she encrypts it by raising it to
the 8th power mod and hopefully with
some padding so it's not horribly broken
so on and so forth that's the cipher
text and Bob decrypt it by raising that
to the dthe power straightforward so the
the only relevant thing for this talk is
the fact that if you can factor the
public modulus then you get the private
key that's basically as deep into our
essay as we're going to go we also saw
that RSA signatures are being used for
RSA it's convenient that signing is
equivalent to just doing the decryption
operation so if alice is going to sign a
message for Bob she raises her message
to the dthe power mod n so using her
private key and then Bob can verify by
checking that the signature raised to
the 8th power mod n is the original
message okay
now this isn't the only crypto that you
use some of you might do something like
this instead so this is my SSH
connection trying to connect to my host
computer see we have we actually have
any ACK at the University of
Pennsylvania there's a big piece of it
in the on the first floor of the lab and
you can still log into it anyway so
here's here's our SSH connection so if
you're doing SSH you're actually not
using well you might use RSA signatures
although this one is using elliptic
curve DSA signatures but if you're using
SSH you are doing a diffie-hellman key
exchange
so yeah has anyone else would know yes
yes like there's some unimaginable
coincidence to find one let alone two
people that have said no to it well I
said no and then I immediately went and
deleted the old fingerprint from my
hosts file in the night and then I said
yes you know fingerprints usability
mm-hmm it's better than nothing I guess
ok so at least sort of the textbook
version of diffie-hellman this I guess
predates RSA but if Alice and Bob want
to guarantee on a shared secret in the
presence of an malicious eavesdropper
who's reading all the messages in
between them and they don't want to say
generate a public key and send it back
and forth they can do the diffie-hellman
key exchange so in sort of the generic
version we've got a group which say is
the integers mod some prime or an
elliptic curve group or whatever and
we've got a generator of that group
these are public parameters and Alice
and Bob exchange values G to the a and G
to the B and then they can compute this
shared secret G to the a B
and the diffie-hellman assumption says
that this is secure if an eavesdropper
sees the transcript of all the messages
G to the a and G to the B they can't can
state still can't construct this value
due to the a B they can hop in the
middle which is why we have this
fingerprint verification that nobody
ever checks that's a little bit I guess
outside of the scope of this talk we're
actually going to you know discuss these
values sort of okay so the security of
diffie-hellman is is based off of the
discrete log problem so a different
cryptographic hardness assumption from
RSA there's also a signature scheme the
digital signature algorithm this is the
u.s. federal standard and its security
is also based off of the hardness of
discrete log either in a group mod some
prime or an elliptic curve group so
we've got for the digital signature
algorithm there's some public parameters
which specify some group and then you've
got a public key which is essentially
what you would give up for it if e home
and although this group is different and
then the private key is the discrete log
of the public value so this is as deep
as we're gonna go into ECDSA but or into
DSA or ECDSA but it's relevant here on
small characteristic finite field
discrete log a couple years ago and they
had really really spectacular results
but these are not known to apply to
large characteristic like the prime
fields that we actually use for crypto
there's also been some recent like very
recent work posted to the eprint archive
about elliptic curve discrete log I
think in binary fields and there it's
unclear what's going on but as far as we
know prime field discrete log is still
the same hardness as it's been for the
past few decades
if you trust that there's nothing else
out there other questions okay so now
that I've sort of given you an overview
of all of the sort of crypto that you
actually encounter in the real world but
I gave you sort of the textbook version
of it sort of the motivating question of
all the work that I'm going to talk
about is what does this crypto actually
look like on a broad scale in the real
world
and the way that we're going to approach
this problem is sort of two steps number
one collect all the cryptographic data
that we can number two look for strange
things going on this is very hand wavy
but that's the general research program
here okay so step number one is collect
data the way that a lot of this work
started was by collecting data on HTTPS
so browsers locks whatever and this
started actually from the SSL
Observatory which was a project which
was run by the e FF they actually n
mapped the entire in ipv4 space and over
the course of several months downloaded
all of the HTTPS certificates they could
posted them online as a gigantic
database and people could download them
and so one day we decided to download
them and see what was there and it
turned out to be way more interesting
than expected and subsequent to that
work some of my collaborators developed
a much faster internet wide scanning
tool so instead of using n map you can
instead and it taking several months you
can instead scan the entire internet in
45 minutes or in five minutes if you
have 100 gigabit uplink so that's V map
it's publicly available you can scan the
Internet they've been posting huge
amounts of data online at scans dot IO
so if you want to repeat any of this
research you can go and download all of
the public keys on the internet for the
past several years so here's a snapshot
of what the internet looked like a few
years ago something like the
about if you basically and met the
internet you see that about 30,000 hosts
will have port 443 open about 30 or 30
million hosts about thirty thirteen
million of them will actually
successfully complete an HTTPS handshake
with you and of that you can download
certificates and you end up with about
5.6 million distinct RSA keys six
million distinct DSA keys a very small
number of ECDSA keys which has gone up
since but it's still quite small because
most certificate authorities don't issue
these and a few hundred ghost keys which
is a Russian cipher suite which is not
commonly used outside of Russia you
could repeat all of this research as you
would like so that's something like what
HTTPS looks like for SSH we did
something similar we scan the entire
ipv4 space on port 22 and initiated an
SSH handshake with the hosts it turns
out that if you scan SSH people really
don't like that they're willing to
accept scanning HTTPS a little bit more
than SSH
so you get a lot of complaints if you do
this nevertheless we've done it here's
something like what it looks like you
find about 23 million open ports of that
about half of them will actually
successfully complete a handshake and
you get 11 million RS a host Keys these
are the keys that are used to verify the
the fingerprints nine point nine million
DSA keys you can see these add up to
more than the number of handshakes
because you get a bunch of most hosts
will give you many different kinds of
host keys you can choose which one you
want 1.2 million ECDSA keys this has
gone up since also and 100 cost keys
then okay what other public key
infrastructures are out there and easy
to scan there's PGP so PGP you can sign
and encrypt your email messages back in
the 90s it seems like a good idea to
have this web of trust and everybody
would post online a nice database of who
all their friends were
with all of their public keys and so you
can easily download a repository of this
web of trust data and when you do that
you find a few million keys there's
actually far fewer RSA keys probably
because in the 90s there was still a
patent on RSA so it was not the default
for PGP and but you do see a lot of El
Kamal and DSA keys for PGP then there's
Bitcoin the Bitcoin database or the
Bitcoin blockchain is also a nice source
of a lot of cryptographic data because
Bitcoin addresses are essentially public
keys transactions require a signature
and so if you just download the
blockchain and scrape it you get a huge
number of public keys and signatures
this data is again kind of old so a
couple years ago there were 15 million
ECDSA public keys in the database and 22
million transactions I'm sure that's
doubled or tripled or multiplied by ten
or something since then
and finally for people who like hardware
this is somewhat of an interesting
example
so Taiwan has this really nifty sort of
a government infrastructure that they
use to the citizens basically get these
little ID cards with a chip in them and
it's a public key infrastructure for
securely connecting to the government so
when you log in to pay your taxes you
can authenticate your connection using
your little smart card chip and you have
a little reader that you can plug your
your card into the computer and you can
do all sorts of transactions with the
government securely this way and in
order to facilitate this and because the
government wants other enterprises to
use this infrastructure that they set up
they have this convenient public key
infrastructure that's the form it takes
the form of an LDAP database of public
key certificates for all of these
Taiwanese citizens and so it is possible
well they've blocked it after we did
this but it was possible to basically
download the contents of the entire LDAP
database
and get public keys and certificates for
about 3 million Taiwanese citizens for
their smart cards so the keys never
leave the chip here but the public keys
are distributed in certificates so these
cards are certified by all of the major
certifying authorities there FIPS 140
certified there Common Criteria
certified so they are supposed to be
resistant to all the sort of standard
side channel analysis that you might do
culture I don't know if he's actually
taking a look at these particular cards
but I'm sure I'm sure whichever lab did
the certification bought some of their
products in order to to certify them
well we're gonna break some of these two
in a different way okay so yes i-i've
been talking about all this cryptography
and this the title of the talk promised
that I would talk about randomness
alright so now we're gonna start talking
about randomness and in moving from
cryptography to randomness well okay you
can say well if you're going to generate
a cryptographic key you need some source
of randomness in order to generate your
your key because you want the attacker
not to be able to predict the value that
you chose for your key therefore it's
easy to say let's use a random number
that will be unpredictable and if you
don't have a good source of random
numbers then an attacker might be able
to guess what your private key was
that's okay you can make that
observation it's not particularly
interesting so is this all that we can
say the answer is of course no because
if any here gives something about like
thousands and thousands of certain hosts
we're using the same key to bear with so
that's that's
so yes
what could you imagine go is going wrong
with bad randomness well you might
expect if you don't have a good source
of randomness then you might expect to
see repeated keys so in the case of say
an RSA public key what would this look
like and as I said before we have our
modulus and and an encryption exponent E
and what what is the value that we care
about is if it's repeated it's not e so
actually basically everybody on the
internet uses the same value of e for
SSL everybody basically uses the value 6
5 5 37 and there's a few small one this
is a log scale so this is for all the
certificates you see a few people using
small values you see almost everybody
using six five five thirty seven and
then almost nothing else is used so it
is not a problem for the security of RSA
if people are sharing the same public
exponent E because that value doesn't
actually hide any of the secrets in the
private key what is a problem is if two
hosts are sharing the same modulus n
because if they have the same modulus
and they have it has the same
factorization and then they both know
the private key of the other so this
means that these hosts would share both
the same public and private keys they
could decrypt messages that were
intended for the other party they could
sign for each other and so and so forth
however there are sort of more subtle
problems that can happen so if not if
two hosts don't just share both prime
factors but if they share exactly one
prime factor of the modulus so in this
case I have two moduli and one is P
times Q 1 and n 2 is P times Q 2 and
they so they share the same prime factor
P then you can compute the GCD of N 1
and n 2 and that will be this value P
and now I've just factored both keys and
this is relevant because there's a big
difference in the time to naively factor
a number versus to compute a GC D so for
768 bit RSA moduli
the current record was set in late 2009
published in 2010 it took about 2.5
calendar years for a team of academics
using a bunch of their computing
clusters to use the number field sieve
to factor a 768 bit RSA modulus in
contrast on my laptop it takes 15
microseconds to compute the GCD of two
1024 bit RSA modulo so there's a little
bit of a difference here yes Euclid's
algorithm were actually you can do
better than you could versus number
field sieve so this is a this would be a
problem if it ever occurred now okay
what about DSA or ECDSA
I can't actually say anything very
intelligent about diffie-hellman keys
you know if you share the same private
key you share the same public key but I
don't know any tricks but it turns out
with the digital signature algorithm
there is a trick because of the way the
signatures are constructed so similar to
diffie-hellman if you to host your the
same private key they'll share the same
public key you can see this in the in
the public value and they could sign for
each other and they both know the
private key for each other
however the signatures themselves are
randomized so they contain a random
nonce and if this nonce is known then it
is possible for a single signature and
you know the public key then it you can
easily compute the private key from the
signal signature and the known daunts
this is an interesting property for a
signature scheme to have and this also
has the property that if your DSA nonce
has ever used to sign this two distinct
messages with the same public key then
you can easily compute the nonce and
from there you can easily compute the
private key that was used so if you ever
once screw up with your DSA
implementation and use the same value to
sign two different messages then your
private key is forever compromised so
okay now we have some things to look for
in the wild in our gigantic database of
key
let's look for them now I'm going to
tell you why they shouldn't work so you
can imagine experiment we take all of
the RSA moduli that we collected off the
internet as I just said we have many
millions of them and we compute the GCD
of each pair of all of the RSA moduli
and if these are say moduli are randomly
chosen then you expect nothing to happen
okay so if you if you say okay so we
have M RSA moduli they have two factors
each and if they are randomly generated
we as okay there so the randomly
generated Prime's and we're essentially
throwing two Prime's into random buckets
at a time until we get a collision so we
can we know what time this will happen
by the birthday bound and we know how
many Prime's there are of say 512 bits
if we're looking at 1024 bit keys from
the prime number theorem and so the
birthday bound tells us that after we
have square root of M Prime's all right
if we have square root of M yeah if we
have both once we have like basically
square root of the total number of
primes then we that's exactly when we
expect a collision and it's pretty sharp
at that bound so if you plot this for
512 bit primes here's this function
it's basically astronomically small
until you get to pretty close to the
number of atoms in the universe and at
that point you do get a non-trivial
probability of a collision but anywhere
sort of below here at reasonable bounds
you get almost nothing it's that a
question numbers the number itself is
not it starts show up substantially
before it goes to B probabilities
approaching 1 so yeah you might you
might well you definitely need to worry
if you're going to have a public key for
every atom in the universe and you might
you might even worry if you have a
public key for every atom in the earth
no this is this is um this is the
function this is this is the probability
of a collision that I plot it here so
that so so this is the square root of
the number of the total number of fronts
but we scale this so it's the actual
number as opposed to the ratio of
probability then we might see halfway of
that curve this is if I if I take a
random like Allah if I take a collection
of M primes randomly generated what's
the probability with my collection of M
Prime's that I see a collision this is
one collision as compared to a collision
one morning yes this is a collision
anywhere in this gigantic database so a
collision with your number will have
probability 1 over the few times the
number of times and or two over the
number of primes and the probability of
any collision follows the birthday don't
I move it's a big number
the the upshot here is that this should
never happen like this is not something
that you should worry about you might
think well ok maybe you should worry you
see you still seem to be worried but
this is not something that talks like
this one because of this just because
the lack of readiness 75 is about half
of 150 so yeah yeah yeah so the circle
there's this short transition between it
not happening and it happening is
happening in yeah square root of 10 to
the 150 but basically this should not
happen there's nothing funny going on
with a distribution of primes there's
nothing funny going on with a number of
prime numbers if your keys were randomly
generated you have nothing to worry
about even for 1024 bit keys which you
probably shouldn't be using anymore
anyway but you know nothing to worry
about
until the next load
okay so despite me proving to you some
of you that this will never happen we
did it anyway
and okay then there's the question of
how do you how do you actually do this
computation so the computation that we
want to do is we want to take all of the
RSA moduli that we downloaded and
compute the pairwise greatest common
divisors of each of them and doing this
in the naive way
so for modulus 1 and module is to
compute GCD of the to check if it's not
1 and continue this is a quadratic
algorithm in the number of moduli that
you have and so you can estimate the
amount of time that it would take which
is sort of just naively 15 microseconds
per computation and total number of
moduli to choose two pairs
that's 1,100 years which is totally not
out of the question if you have a giant
cluster but I did this when I was a
postdoc and so I didn't have a giant
cluster so we had to be a little bit
more clever and so the way that we were
more clever it turns out that there's a
much more efficient algorithm for
accomplishing this which was published
by Dan Bernstein in 2004 he put up a
paper it was actually an algorithm used
for finding pairwise smooth numbers in
preparation for a standard factoring
algorithm but we can repurpose it for
our purposes here it contains a bunch of
sort of common tricks from the
computational number theory community
and so the way the algorithm works you
can implement this in about 15 lines of
Python it's pretty straightforward but
basically you compute this gigantic
binary tree which is called a product
tree where each each node is the product
of its two parents until you get the
product of all of the RSA moduli on the
internet this is a really big number it
was so big that we broke GMP in doing
this that's how big it was then you
compute a remainder tree you go back
down the tree and mod out by the squares
of each node and then in the tree at the
end you end up with the product of
everything mod each element squared you
can divide out by that element and then
at this point we have basically
the product of everything but and one
and we can take the GCD of that and n1
and that will tell us if any everything
but N 1 and N 1 has some non-trivial
common factor around so this is poly
logarithmic so you have a log number of
nodes in the in the tree and each of
each the number of operations going
across actually sort of multiplication
is it scales like n poly log n rather
than like N squared in the number of
bits and so you're accumulating a bunch
of poly log n factors but the the total
number of operations on each node is a
proxy is within a poly log factor for
each one and so we have basically were
near we start with like linear and in
the number a total number of moduli
elements and so each each node in the
tree takes like m poly log n operations
with some poly with some poly log and
like the length of the tree there's we
have more efficient code written in C
using GMP which is more than 15 lines of
code it's available online if you want
to run this or is actually the best
enough to do this it starts to break so
it this will so Python will work for
like a few million keys it'll start to
brick to break when you get to like 5 or
10 million keys just because of memory
management it starts to to die all your
time in any case so the language doesn't
make much difference yeah except that
the the big barrier here is that this is
a gigantic data structure this thing is
huge
and so if this gets to be more than like
your total amount of memory then you
have to start like reading you know yeah
you either start paging or you have to
read and write from disk it gets a
little bit unfortunate yes so we had to
this takes hundreds of gigabytes to
store and so we had to do all this
mucking around writing it to disk and
whatnot that was the part where GMP
broke is because they're using a sign
32-bit integer for the size of the
numbers that you're running to disk and
we exceeded that did everything on the
internet hood was more than 2 to the 31
yeah okay now that we've done this
computation or mentally and you can do
it you know tonight at home after you go
home you can download some code download
some keys alright so what actually does
happen well it turns out that you
compute the private keys for 64,000 HTTP
servers so that's about half a percent
of the hosts on the internet 2500 SSH
servers - PGP users and you discover a
bunch of invalid keys that happen to be
in the database and 103 Taiwanese
citizens so that's not what you are
supposed to be finding what happens if
you go through and look for repeated DSA
nonces it turns out that you can compute
the private keys for 1% of all of the
SSH servers with DSA keys and 158
Bitcoin addresses ok what happens if you
just look for repeated keys well
something like 60% of the HTTP and ssh
hosts serve non unique public keys which
is kind of a shocking number because
from a theoretical perspective you know
the first thing that you do when you do
cryptography is like generate a random
public key and clearly the internet is
not doing that it turns out that there's
a lot of reasons that are not
vulnerabilities that hosts share public
keys in practice their thing you know
shared hosting situations where you have
a single hosting provider and a bunch of
who's either issuing presumably HTTPS
certificates for all of their hosts or
you have an ssh kind of gateway that has
a bunch of different IP
dresses behind it that's probably not a
vulnerability you have many
organizations who register lots of
domain names with the same key so Google
calm and google.org and Google dot MX or
Google thought fr it's not a
vulnerability if they share the same
public key because it's one organization
they have the they presumably have their
own infrastructure you also see a lot of
expired certificates that are just
renewed with the same key which this is
just standard practice although
apparently after the heartbleed
vulnerability last year when everybody
was told get a new HTTPS certificate a
lot of people went out and got new HTTPS
surfeit certificates with the same
public key that they had before sort of
missing the point but their key might be
compromised so that case is bad but but
in general if you are just getting a new
certificate you don't need to change
your key every every year there are a
lot of common reasons that are
vulnerabilities to share keys a really
common one is device default
certificates so you know a little a
router manufacturer might just burn in a
certificate into the firmware of the
device and so you will have tens of
thousands or millions of devices out
there that all have exactly the same
keys and people have reverse engineered
these things and published databases of
the private keys for them the one reason
relevant to us is things like a entropy
problems in key generation which we can
start to estimate but it's hard to
really ask it a rigorous estimate
because of all of the device default
certificates and then there's also
things like virtual machine snapshots so
if you generate a virtual machine and
you set up everything the way you like
it you you snapshot it you distribute it
to everybody in the internet well you
already generated the SSH host keys and
so everybody who spins up an instance of
that snapshot will end up with the same
host keys and we started to see a little
bit of that it's also very difficult to
get proper estimates of that because I
don't know how to tell if something is a
virtual machine or not out there on the
internet so these are some massive
massive lower bounds just from
basically hand counting places where
these reasons were clearly identifiable
so default certificates for HTTPS
at least 5% of hosts are sharing keys
because of default certificates or keys
for a low entropy I'm sure it's actually
much higher but 0.3 percent can be
manually identified this must be an
entropy problem it's not some kind of
device default and then for SSH about
10% of hosts are sharing public keys
because of either default or low entropy
keys massive lower bounds like isolate
the low entropy situation how do you
just turn I I'm not even seeing how this
is happening which is so it's kind of an
aesthetic judgment so um I guess I I
didn't mention that here the if you
connect to a machine and it says my ssh
implementation is like this router
manufacturer and then if you look at all
of the hosts that had that banner
further ssh implementation and then you
see a distribution that falls off like
this in the distribution of what their
public keys are then you say that looks
like an entropy problem rather than that
they were building it depended on the
implementation but if we saw that like
everything shared the everything from
that identified itself as being from a
particular manufacturer had exactly the
same key that looks like a default key
if there was some kind of thing
distribution that looked like it came
out of a random process then that looks
like an entropy problem I can't prove it
to you but that's awfully suspicious and
then in cases where we definitely knew
that what was happening was because of
an entropy problem then we could see
some of these distributions repeated in
so this is kind of a qualitative
judgment on my part ok
did I what did I do here I broke my
thing well okay so here is if you look
at the most commonly repeated keys on
the Internet so this is the most
commonly 50 most commonly repeated RSA
SSH keys and you just say what is their
banner what IPS are they being served
from can we identify why these keys are
repeated here's something like what you
see the most commonly repeated SSH key
is from Vario so a big internet hosting
provider my parents actually have an
account on Vario so I went in and
checked whether I could see the private
key and I couldn't so I decided it was
not a vulnerability the next several
most common are all obviously devices
various kinds of routers and firewalls
and what you see as you go down is a
hosting provider device device hosting
provider device device something else or
I'm not sure and so nearly all of them
were shared either because they were big
hosting providers where probably they
just managed their own infrastructure
and it's not a problem or it's some
family a device that has some kind of
baked in default key for the TLS
certificates that were that we factored
when we went and looked at those the
vast vast majority of them were not
browser trusted certificates so they
were not signed by a certificate
authority nobody paid money for these
things and the web pages for the two
that were had been signed by certificate
authorities weren't active when we were
looking at him so these subject
information for their certificates looks
something like this
if you go and refactor all of the
vulnerable keys and so they say okay
self signed system generated or they
identify here's a printer there's a
router so these are all sort of clearly
auto-generated certificates from various
kinds of devices that list things like
serial numbers these aren't banks
so this is sort of a clue that what we
were looking at was not sort of a
widespread problem generic problem in
crypto implementation it's a problem
somehow isolated to devices and in
particular things like routers and
firewalls which actually you think the
internet is real computers it turns out
that if you just scan the internet what
you see is devices there's a huge number
of things out there so the Internet of
Things is already here in some sense so
these implementation problems for
devices it wasn't it also wasn't that
there was a single family of device that
was vulnerable that that had made some
mistake it was across all nearly all of
the major manufacturers so every name in
the industry that you can think of we
saw represented in the vulnerable keys
that we found so there were various
kinds of network security devices so
these juniper network security devices
were more than half of the factored
HTTPS certificates and there's another
commonality with family tree that even
though they're different manufacturers
someone may have bought a license to
someone else's design so a lot of these
things are running some version of
embedded Linux on on some little
processor and there's there's a few
distribution I mean you know the the
generic thing that we can say is okay
they're probably running SSH on some
version of embedded Linux on some little
version of some version of hardware that
specialized to them that was sort of the
most generic but juniper doesn't follow
that so juniper has its own operating
system which is based on BSD and there
were actually several different versions
of Linux there were several different
versions of SSH hosts and and whatnot so
it wasn't it wasn't all because of some
shared family tree there was a lot of
shared keys because of shared family
trees but there were a lot of different
implementations that were clearly having
similar kinds of problems so yeah we
identified devices for more than 50
manufacturers it's every name that you
can think of
and all sorts of interesting things like
firewalls for power plants cell towers
power yeah power grid things HVAC
systems printers like yes yes the that
is a very astute observation gaseous
centrifuges to thankfully hopefully I
never will Def Con I'm just curious
I think twice ok alright so I want to
talk a little bit about sort of the big
picture of what these implementations
are doing ok so if you think of your
little device it wants to generate a
crypt okay you tree you you plug it in
you turn it on it says I'm going to boot
up my SSH process now I'm going to
generate my host P okay so what does it
need well it needs to generate its its
host key now and it needs a source of
randomness where does it get it well
there's some whatever this is ssh
process is it has its some application
specific pseudo-random number generator
hopefully coming from some library like
open ssl the way that this application
specific random number generator is
going to generate numbers well it's
going to take randomness from all the
sources that it can which are basically
the time the pit and maybe the operating
system entropy pool because the
operating system is kind enough to
provide a source of random numbers but
it doesn't have access the the
application itself doesn't have access
to a lot more than that then okay where
does the operating system get its
entropy from well it takes its inputs
from say keyboards Mouse's hard disk
timings network interrupts that kind of
information okay so if you think about
these little devices you plug it in you
turn it on it starts its SSH process
it's never it might not even be hooked
up to the to the network it doesn't have
a keyboard it doesn't have a mouse and
it probably doesn't have a hard disk so
all of the sources
of entropy that the operating system was
expecting arch present it might even be
plugged hooked up for the first time in
on the in the factory and so it's never
you know it's not even done yet second
when the application decides to query
for random numbers from the operating
system even if the operating system had
access to entropy it might not have
actually incorporated it into its
entropy pool at the time when it was
queried by the application and this was
actually a vulnerability in Linux that
we experimental event verified that
there was essentially a boot time
entropy hole so if you started up your
Linux distribution it would wait until
it had a certain amount of entropy and
in order to mix that into the main pool
for output if you queried you random or
a dev random or W random because it was
they were worried about the possibility
of somebody of an attacker sort of
carefully tracking the entropy sources
so you want to mix in lots of entropy
all at once so it would look random but
it won't block you random and so I mean
this is you know I you guys all have
beards I assume that you all using Linux
all the time so Linux has these two
random number generators
there's devran I'm a dev you random and
a dev random says I'm high-quality
randomness you should think of me as you
know information theoretically secure
even though it's not and dev you random
makes no promises and it only says I'm
the output of a pseudo-random number
generator but it never blocks and if you
read man random it says as the general
rule W random should be used for
everything except long-lived GPG SSL SSH
keys but the issue here is that the very
conservative blocking behavior of random
is a usability problem so random will
try to measure the amount of entropy
that's going in and coming out and try
to make sure that they never give out
more entropy that came in you can
quibble about how good their estimation
of entropy is it's probably not very
good
some people showed a couple years ago
but this is overkill even for proper
cryptography all you care is that your
pseudo-random number generator has been
seeded once you don't care about
continual seeding and because of that
you know you this little router it's
probably never going to get an output
from dev random so what's the developer
going to you do they're going to say
well screw it I'm just going to use you
random the difference between random and
you random is some theoretical academic
concern that doesn't apply to me
generators are perfectly fine for
cryptography as long as they are seeded
with uniformly random inputs once you
see yeah okay once you've seeded them
with sufficiently large say 256 bits of
uniformly random inputs then a
cryptographically secure pseudo-random
number generator is everything that you
need for the rest of your life it's not
just the factor that's 256 this and its
underlying representation of that can be
exploited for vulnerabilities well
you're saying if you can get at the
underlying hardware or the operating
system why are these doing that
processor you can grab the right number
or the seed yeah so there might be other
vulnerabilities if you can recover the
state and the like but assuming that
those are not a problem then there is
this hole yes during the initialization
there is this hole and this hole is the
problem so here is a developer for one
of the most commonly used SSH
implementations on these little embedded
devices saying I give up I'm not going
to use dev random because it will never
provide any output so if system
developers aren't getting seeds between
boots nor getting any entropy from
somewhere it's their own fault give the
problem to somebody else ok
so right I have established that there
is this problem at boot time which the
Linux developers have fixed they have
issued a patch they change the behavior
of Linux at boot time it will be much
more aggressive in incorporating entropy
into its pools and it will also take it
from more sources now so post-2012 bsd
did not have nearly as widespread
problems because they were better at
seeding on boot there were a couple of
vulnerabilities in bsd several years ago
where they had boot time entropy seeding
issues but those were result it was in
summer of 2012 and they were extremely
responsive it's very impressive
basically like we emailed them and had a
response from leanness in like half an
hour and there were there were patches
by the end of the day yeah ok so i've
established that there's this entropy
problem i haven't established how this
generates keys that we can actually
factor so at this point you might
believe me that we there are reasons why
we would see many many repeated keys due
to entropy problems in the wild but why
are we seeing keys that are sharing one
prime but not both ok so if you think
about here's the sort of cartoon version
of how you might think to implement RSA
in software so you might your
application might seed its its
pseudo-random number generator and then
it says give me a random prime give me
another prime multiply them together
that's my modulus and so if you know
obviously if you haven't seeded your
pseudo-random number generator or it
seeded always with the same value then
you expect to see large numbers of
shared keys and these repeated Keyser's
assign that you might be vulnerable to a
targeted attack but this does not
explain since the pseudo-random number
generator is going to be a deterministic
process why we might CP share
not you yeah so if you if you are adding
randomness from some entropy source in
between generating P and Q then you
might expect to share one prime but not
two and but if you look at something
like open SSL it's not adding an obvious
source of randomness so what open SSL
does is every time you get a big numb
the pseudo-random number generator it
will add the current time in seconds
into the pool which does not sound like
a very good source of entropy because
the time has to be the same if you were
getting the same seed out of the random
number generator in the first place so
it turns out that due to clock drift
different devices can have slightly
different notions of their CPU time
versus the real time and if the real
time ticks on a slightly different cycle
of the CPU than for the actual then the
devices then you can add up with just
enough entropy to produce this nice
distribution of shared Prime's that we
were seeing in the wild there is is
holding as a constant is that what I'm
saying that there's a little bit of
these devices one might have its clock
running a little bit faster than the
other and so if you imagine two devices
here that both start up they both think
that it's unix time zero and then they
start moving forward and as they're
generating their keys that key
generation process they start with the
same seed and then they have to query
many many big gnomes in order to
generate a prime and as they do that
then one of them is running slightly
slower than the other and if the clock
ticks on a slightly different iteration
of querying a big number of the random
number generator
then they will see different values and
then the state of the random number
generator will diverge from there
afterwards doesn't have a time at all so
it thinks it's use time zero and it
starts ticking forward for America no
how is it how is it counting time it's
kind of time and machine cycles it has
something real time clock on it well but
they don't even all count in the small
but LST sounds a little increment by
some tick amount in other words they're
artifacts of the least significant bits
of the time of day that are not rentable
we need sample so my picture here is
that we've got a CPU clock and we've got
a real-time clock so the real-time clock
gets powered from starting from when you
start it up it would have a battery
behind it know what time it was but it
was never seated with the time because
it's never been plugged in before that's
okay about this concept it's clear to me
and I understand the variability purple
all computers in the conventional
community we're all different
I don't know what you think of it as a
significant difference what do you think
a number that I can associate with the
variability it's going to depend on the
device that you're so anxious what
what's your cause of a variability yeah
that's acceptable or necessary well in
this case I I don't care what the
variability is all that I care about is
that it's generating some distribution
yeah the so there's there's entropy it's
going to it's going to vary a lot
depending on the actual clock speed of
the devices I don't want this to be the
source of entropy that I'm actually
using to generate the keys I want to
have actually had a good seed so I the
manufacturers can use whatever value
for exactness of their clock that they
want and I will that's fine but that
shouldn't be their source of entropy for
cryptography it's fine you can see for
them yeah
so we tried to model this scenario if
you know I guess you guys all say you
believe me but if you don't believe that
this might happen we actually took a
normal PC shut down as many processes as
we could and fixed a seed for OpenSSL
and said generate me a key and if you do
this many thousands of times you see a
beautiful distribution of different P's
and Q's that get generated depending on
exactly where in the key generation
cycle that this second was ticking and
it depends on the speed and all sorts of
other things okay I'm getting a low on
time here should I should I like wrap up
now or should I keep going for you guys
are more fun than grad students okay so
now maybe you believe why why we see
factorable RSA keys why are we seeing
these repeated DSA nonces so the DSA
nonces are being generated in real time
during the actual sort of running of
these devices and even if you have a
horrible little device that doesn't have
any seeds on first boot it's been up for
some period of time when we actually
were scanning the Internet and hopefully
it's actually incorporated some entropy
into its entropy pool by then but it
turns out that when we require heed a
lot of these devices that were
generating keys what we found was that
they were generating a deterministic
sequence of nonces and the sequence is
coming because the application-specific
random number generator is seeding
itself once and then deterministic
deterministic lis ticking forward
which is a perfectly fine model if you
have a good cryptographic seed it is not
a good model if you don't have a good
cryptographic cryptographically secure
seed and so the reason that we were
seeing colliding nonces in many cases
was because you might you can imagine
say ten thousand different routers all
from the same manufacturer and they were
all started with the same state and then
they got queried different numbers of
times and so we will see two nonces
collide in a single scan if two of these
routers two of these 10,000 happened to
be in the same state when we collided
them but if we go back and then ask for
a hundred different values from there
their pools then we will see eventually
more collisions so this explained some
but not all of the problems there were a
few manufacturers who just didn't
understand that you needed to generate
different values for every signature
this is apparently a not uncommon
problem with it's pretty easy to
generate a good cryptographically secure
pseudo-random number generator at this
time I mean a yes encounter mode is is
great right representatives and all 50
vendors oh it was it was a horrible
experience I've got a slide but that
summarizes this at the end so you'll
hopefully get to okay so what about
these smart card keys so some of you
were very interested in these smart card
keys if we went and looked at the primes
that we saw when we actually factored
these keys this was the most common
factor that we saw this does not look
like a random number yes this is the
first prime after 2 to the 511 plus 2
the 510 so they clearly have some other
issues the next most common factor is
this value which isn't quite the same
but you see this is also not quite a
random number either it's not quite
periodic but it's like pretty
pretty close and basically by
extrapolating patterns so this is
actually it turns out to be a repeated
bit pattern but they were swapping sum
of two every two words in the
representation so by sort of
extrapolating patterns of that form
incrementing to the next prime we
factored eighty more keys and also by
using some more fun lattice based math
to break things that had some some bit
errors there okay it could have been a
lot of sort of comments on the internet
for like oh my god is this an NSA
backdoor it's most likely not course
since you know Dan Bernstein pretty well
do you have any sense of whether the
elliptic curve standard in this standard
is has weaknesses that are not found in
the Bernstein curve there are no
publicly known vulnerabilities that
these curves could have so these curves
don't have any of the publicly known
properties that might make it easier to
solve the discrete log problem on them
but that's the only answer that we can
really give right I mean you can you can
quibble about the random number
generation process which is part of what
dan and Tanya are sort of doing is that
the provably at random parameter
generation process that they used is not
as at all provably at random which is a
little bit annoying but we don't know of
anything they're probably fine I mean we
can use curve to 55.9 if you trust Dan
more than the NSA yeah
I I mean it's like NSA with whatever
gigantic budget that they have and
however many hundred thousand employees
and Dan look at the NSA s budget of X
and a budget of minus X or the other
half of the house I think your point is
that the NSA will require an exponential
number of dollars to keep up with the
engine do we need a few scholars well
but do you really want to have the
security of the entire internet rely on
one guy who could be hit by a bus
tomorrow I mean can we invent this work
but it will require an exponential
number of dollars really NSA to compete
with that
they will require millions and millions
of mathematicians to basically counter a
few good crypto engineers they don't
realize this yet doesn't they're gonna
find out ok so how many how many NSA
employee is this Dan worth how do we
know he's not the best factor that they
had dual ec drbg was like not a very
good backdoor right people people saw
through that one within a few years but
the NSA curves we don't have anything on
that right or the the NIST curve sir
it's more entertaining all right so
these smart card keys you guys like
smart cards so all right why are these
government certified smart cards
generating private keys they we know how
to generate good random numbers in
hardware so the all of the standards so
the FIPS 140 standards the Common
Criteria whatever they sort of have a
list of things best practices that you
should do the designers should
characterize the entropy there should be
some testing of the entropy source at
runtime to double-check that it's not
outputting all zeroes or repeating of
values or whatever and then you should
post-process this entropy source by
running it through some kind of PR ng
hash function something to whiten it
right so this is basically like the big
picture idea of how you should generate
your random numbers anywhere really but
also in hardware and these cards that
are generating Prime's that look like
that are clearly doing none of these
things even though they were claimed to
be fips-compliant and so we actually
never got our hands on one of these
cards
but our hypothesized failure was that
there was actually a hardware failure in
the underlying entropy source that would
fail in some situations so our
hypothesis is that a lot of times these
cards are doing some kind of they have
some kind of like ring oscillator that
should have some kind of chaotic
interaction but if it got stuck then it
might sort of output these periodic
values that we were seeing and so if in
some situations it's outside of the
proper temperature or it got hit by a
hammer or something maybe it would it
would get stuck and we would see
actually values where it would it would
get stuck and then it would get unstuck
so that's one problem and then the card
software was actually not being operated
in Phipps compliance mode and so that
meant that there was no testing and no
post-processing of the random number
generator output pointing out it gets
stuck though which is to say some random
number generators be not going to there
to equilibrium so they don't generate
this usually there's a metastable
process and these things they servo
flip-flop the sampling and they wait for
the medicine to fall out and if the
system isn't finishing high it is yes
those those who don't write our programs
randomly the fact that they do behave
randomly on their own
so we have unintentional randomness
which is far too common now you're
telling me that intentional you what you
want is no randomness when you don't
want any randomness and you want perfect
randomness when you do want randomness
and yes and sadly the the real world is
somewhere in between I think there's
this you also have to add the operating
system cognitive you also want this as
an atomic operation mm-hmm yeah we
actually one interesting thing with
Linux is that we saw a little bit of
entropy coming from basically it was not
an atomic operation and so different
different processes were reading the
pool at slightly different times and
getting some amount of randomness just
from sort of non-deterministic behavior
for when when different processes would
be reading even when the the the stream
that was being output was was continuous
ever was deterministic unintentional
entropy I think the big message here is
that a lot of programmers I mean you
want to think about entropy as something
you press a button and you get entropy
but it turns out that entropy is
actually something like an environmental
resource that you have to wait for that
you're not guaranteed but that's not the
model that that all of people all the
people writing programs want to to treat
it as you want it to just be a function
call rather than some kind of blocking
resource yeah well I mean we don't want
normal people to have to think about
cryptography cryptography should be one
of those invisible magical things that
just makes everything function and the
fact that developers are having to think
about cryptography is also a serious
issue okay so what about PGP we should
expect to the developers of PGP they
should be paranoid they are using dev
random to generate their keys why are we
seeing common why are we seeing
factorable keys it turns out that this
was probably not
the PGP developers implementation it was
a different plugin that was generating
these vulnerable keys both of the keys
were more than ten years old they were
generated by German speakers German
speakers were unhappy to find out that
their keys were compromised but they
were not currently being used so
hopefully it is an implementation error
in an implementation that's no longer
being used and this is a rare
implementation error for Bitcoin there's
actually been a number of different
incidents there was a Java random number
generator vulnerability that was
publicized in August 2013 they were not
renewing the state of the pool when the
process forked and so different
different processes can end up with the
same pool state and then generate the
same nonces we also saw a bunch of test
implementations of people who are sort
of obviously not putting values or the
correct you know they were just putting
in all zeros or whatever there is a
particular Bitcoin address that has been
systematically searching the blockchain
for the past several years for repeated
nonces and systematically stealing all
of the bitcoins from anybody whoever
repeats a signature this is this is an
old number I have no idea how much they
have now but yeah so that this means
that math pays not as much as it used to
but in case ok so you were asking about
the disclosure issues this was a
interesting process for me so I
personally wrote email disclosures to 61
companies of those 61 companies which
are sort of it's like a random sampling
of tech companies including all of
basically the major names 13 of those
companies had some kind of security team
contact that I could find on their
website the rest of them I had to just
guess so
you guessed I don't know tech support
and what else
I did get through to some of them so
ultimately I ended up receiving some
kind of response from 28 some of those
came only after cert got involved I
didn't realize that I could just you
know go to certain say please contact
these companies for me I have too many
too contact since then 13 of them have
told us that they have fixed the problem
five of those published some kind of
public security advisory so actually so
one of the companies contacted ics-cert
the industrial control system cert
because they made industrial control
systems to report the vulnerability and
at that point ics-cert contacted us and
asked us to verify this and we said you
know we have all these other companies
too and so they helpfully helped chase
down several of the companies who hadn't
responded before and so they were very
helpful in this as I said the linux
kernel has been patched they were
extremely responsive and since the
original publication we have seen a
decrease in the number of hosts serving
factorable
after the cert organization
that yeah I don't know how many these
things to head up or Hannity overlap 61
how are there 20 levels so there's okay
so there's 61 - 28 who have never
responded to us maybe some of them fixed
it maybe they haven't
so the 28 includes everybody who told us
anything ever that was anything that
sounded like a human response
you